all right good evening i'm lieutenant
ray spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department
i'm out here this evening to brief you
on a homicide investigation that we are
conducting
in the 3600 block of east owens
the details that i have right now are
very preliminary but at around 6 30
tonight
metro police responded on a report of a
woman who had been
shot patrol officers and medical
personnel arrived
and located a black female in her early
30s suffering from a gunshot wound
police officers attempted to render aid
prior to her being transported to umc
trauma where she was pronounced deceased
what we have learned is that the victim
was inside of the apartment
when an unknown male who was inside the
apartment
fired at least what we believe to be one
round
from a high-powered rifle striking and
killing her
that male then fled out the door on foot
i urge
anyone who has any information to please
reach out to crime stoppers
the information is completely anonymous
and there is reward money available
you can also reach out to homicide at
lvmpd.com
with any information so again still very
early on there are multiple people
inside the apartment that we are
speaking with right now
and trying to determine what transpired
i'll take a couple questions if you have
them
we don't right now when we originally
responded there were people inside the
apartment who fled
and we're still trying to piece it all
together so we don't know the
relationship between the male
and the deceased
speak up for me i'm sorry yes the victim
does live inside the apartment
how many people were inside uh there's
at least
several five to six that we know of but
there potentially could be more
inside the apartment that fled prior to
police arrival and
no one no one knew who this person was
that tired of the shot
right now it's still too early we're
trying to determine if anyone did
know from the initial interviews with
witnesses we're not able to determine
that at this point
we're in the process of canvassing the
apartment complex and looking for
surveillance video
she was already inside the apartment
when the round
struck strucker right we don't know
about any type of building at this time
we don't we're still trying to figure
that out as far as like i said there
were a lot of people who fled prior
to us arriving so we're still trying to
piece those details out
again we don't know the specifics of
what the
what transpired uh they're again
speaking with witnesses we're trying to
piece all that together
thank you guys appreciate it